At Tokyo's Haneda Airport, a futuristic testing program is underway.
It's a sign companies are taking Prime Minister Shinzo Abe's Reform 2020 project seriously,...
...one that sets the Tokyo Olympics as a benchmark for introducing advanced technologies...
...including customer service robots.
For both tech companies and Japan itself,...
...the Olympic Games, with a potential global audience of around 3.5 billion,...
...could be an ideal shop window.
Taking this opportunity, we directly introduce such a kind of technology worldwide.
The concept of showing off its high-tech expertise when the world is watching isn't new here.
Just ten days before the 1964 Olympics, Japan launched the high-speed Shinkansen bullet train.
The drive towards 2020 has hatched fresh transport initiatives.
With Nissan, Internet company DeNA is aiming to have driverless taxis available during the Olympics.
It's also working on a robotic delivery car for logistics company, Yamoto.
Space entertainment firm ALE is another company...
...looking to launch its technology, man-made meteors, in time for the Games.